well as has been abundantly clear
throughout the show so far we still
don't really know where we are with
brexit bad news for businesses desperate
for an end to the uncertainty and
joining us now as the Director General
or the British chamber of commerce at a
Marshall thanks very much for being with
us so what is going through the minds of
business men and women as they watch
what's going on in Westminster there's a
huge amount of frustration and anger out
there in our business communities Sophie
people have been waiting for three years
for an outcome to this whole process and
what they see is continued political
tactics continued positioning and no
clear route forward so for many in
business out there this is one of the
most frustrating times that they've
lived through what did you make her fee
interview with the Chancellor well we
think it's extraordinarily important to
avoid a messy and disorderly exit
previously that was on March the 29th
now that's on April the 12th the
difference of a fortnight makes very
little difference to businesses that
cliff edge that possibility is still
very much there and businesses want to
avoid it so it's helpful to hear a
number of politicians including the
Chancellor of the Exchequer expressing
their determination to avoid that sort
of exit I mean some people who are
brexit supporters would say that
actually businesses need to embrace the
opportunities if No Deal there were
plenty of things that the government can
do to make us more attractive to
business and we should just take the
plunge and be optimistic about it well
businesses are resilient and they're
going to embrace the opportunities of
whatever situation they end up finding
themselves in but that doesn't mean they
don't need a route forward they've been
watching this for three years many of
them have had to take some very drastic
decisions in their own businesses in
order to prepare for all scenarios so
what kind of things you're talking about
we talked about job cants relocations
but we've got people cancelling
investment we have one company in the
West Midlands for example contacted us
last week that is going to mothball its
UK operation because its investors and
owners want to quote move to a more
stable country that's where our politics
is left quite a lot of our businesses in
Kent for example right now companies
preparing for a situation where there's
total gridlock on the roads and people
can't even go about their day-to-day
business these are the kinds of things
happening in the real world right now
and to everyone in politics whether they
be in government or in Parliament
they need to get a grip of this very
quickly because these impacts are real
and they're out there you obviously have
a lot of conversations with ministers
with members of government with advisors
and so on are you confident that they
actually have a grip on what's happening
do they have a plan or they just feel in
their way
well I think they are certainly
listening to some of these concerns for
business but we have yet to see that
clear and concrete route forward I
looked at the Sunday newspapers this
morning and actually I was quite
depressed by what I saw because it was
all about the who rather than about the
what what we're concerned about at the
moment is what is that path forward what
is the time line that businesses are
going to have in order to adjust to a
new reality whatever that may be and
where are the practical answers to the
real world questions that they're
ringing us up and asking every single
day you mentioned this on their
newspapers of course they're full of
news of Coos plots against the Prime
Minister I mean do you think that would
be helpful to have a new prime minister
who might be able to find a way forward
or do you think that actually this is a
distraction and it could be worse well
when you have companies out there saying
to you I don't know who I can hire in a
couple of weeks time I don't know who my
regulator is I'm not sure if my goods
are going to reach people that I'm
selling them to across the world and I
really do not sure what's going to
happen to my business that's the real
world stuff and I think the frustration
and anger you get out there amongst
businesses is that the politics is all
about what's going on in Westminster
there needs to be a lot more of a focus
on the economic realities and the need
to avoid that messy and disorderly
outcome that business does not want to
see okay Adam Marshall thank you very
much for the update on what businesses
are currently thinking thank you much
appreciated